tria risultati su forgotten tunnel spero
che vi piaccia continuo buon isola
ragazzi perché ma portando ma dai non mi
fa fare la fine quell'altro porca [ __ ]
no basata su una barella ma non mi sta
affascinando stop e sente c'è gente meno
male mi stai portando tu perché sta
gente qua non l'avrei superata il nuovo
le dico lo sta portando in mezzo a cose
carine
sto passando di sotto dove prima vedevo
che c'era un piano
ok non mi pare cose brutte perché io
sono una persona simpatica c'è sotto può
essere anche giocherellone possiamo
giocare se vuoi a metà slug fa una
partita e io al crossing bel momento ce
la vedo veramente un fratello zio
sì però dove casi si sta portando andava
in macchina facevo prima azione perché
anch'io mi stai portando dovrà cioè mi
sembra un po eccessivo c'è una ventola
rossa che thanks for playing no perché
sono portato quanto le devo per il
servizio taxi non so mi dica lei beh non
ho fatto la fine di questi qua che già
qualcosa
ho tolto secondo sigillo la gamma è
successo piove il patto dell'oscurità
mi mancava il patto dell'oscurità
ragazzi c'è proprio non vedevo l'ora
ho detto mica per speriamo che facciamo
al patto dell'oscurità proprio show by
turn e mamma mia come voglio farlo
questo patto dell'oscurità invece a el
ha vinto la di prima ok sono sopra
adesso dopo chissà che cosa è servito
esattamente non ho ben capito starò e
signori nell'oscurità domanda dove lo
faccio il fatto devo accettare tipo i
contratti tipo quella roba quando
scrollo tutto non leggo niente faccia
c'è tanto dolore ma mi sta seguendo
qualcosa questa musica mi sta seguendo
niente però vabbè vendo cose potrebbe
essere il patto dell'oscurità che sta
per arrivare in 3 2 1 ma non lo so c'è
un apporto molto evidenziata e io vado
sempre i due allora ragazzi mi
raccomando sempre due allora perché la
morte si attende ma proprio attende
camminate piano aspetta che qua mi do
anch'io tra i pianisti comunque non
fossero di nel senso girl ma si tanto
guarda è la cosa più è la cosa più
allegra che mi è successa oggi live c'è
di nuovo la palla di crash bandicoot
posso rientrare
no vabbè di melo non rientra salirlo g
no non puoi la seguente nas
intraprendere a cadere senza chi entra
chi è mai entrato qualche ieri vedi qua
cazzo serve sa ma sto facendo questo
gira cosa girato esattamente cos'è un
boss nápoles battle east is a boss
battle cazzo ma ogni volta che si gira
verso di me io ho una sang hwa ta in
faccia non ho capito per quale motivo
sto tirando su roba però non ho capito
cosa e non so quanto mi manca tra
l'altro erano tirati su un sacco di muri
a quanto vedo vediamo se dato tutto sia
andato bene
vediamoci ma io non ho capito cos'è che
sto tirando su i muri
e mo ma che cazzo è servito sta roba
fuso
ci sono tutti noi ne manca uno che
quello lassù lo vedo
manca solo quello dritto e poi ho finito
da fango la questo qua fatto adesso li
ho tirati tutti su non ce n'è uno che
manca pro giuro lo posso giurare sanno
tutti stanno stanno tutti lo zio dove si
alza 18 lo fatti e li ho fatti tutti ci
stanno tutti i muri non ho capito a cosa
sono serviti ma va bene allora ma sto
coso lo devo attivare una eccolo
funziona mi sto sparando i laser non so
come ma va bene va bene scavalca mista a
fan culo ma accovacciato mai più veloce
mai picchiato mi piace sto dietro fino
quasi a su luca due ore e mezza per
farlo fuori però va bene ma se starò da
poi è successo non ho capito che sono
che ansia ma dailan non può essere un
teletrasporto continuo sta di nuovo
stage ensor minchia tutto all'inizio
rifacciamo rifacciamolo è stato bello
rifacciamolo ma veramente quindi non gli
porta fuori porta pari al boss finale
rami di portare fuori le ventole la
donna l'aria cui serviva in questo
momento pare già murci perché ce lo
siamo meritato ragazza effettivamente
cosa e fini è finito costruire la
scienza non è un gioco di daniel
francisco dei proiettili proiettile
perso va bene
vabbè cosa vi devo dire io sono molto
emozionato in questo momento ma comunque
una cavalcata bella grossa grazie a
francisco dei problemi gli enti con
l'impero che questo credo che sia
piaciuto erano forgotten tunnels
forgotten lasers forgotten gente che
sting chance e forgotten ascensore tutte
cose forgotten effettivamente però spero
che vi sia piaciuto è stato un bel gioco
ho sudato dall'ansia dal caldo dentro si
suda nel mio studio
thank you for play in thank you for
making this game my brother mi chiami
farti nominarono l'aspettavo park a
[ __ ] cascata la scienza non è finito
ma come come non finisce qualcosa c'è
quello pezzetto ma dai ma hanno trovato
ma hanno trovato tantissimo mi hanno
preso per il culo c'è la finale abusivi
ma non ho più paura di niente dopo web
che figata a si stanno chiedendo le cose
ok è il primo gioco che che assegna a
rimettere un qualcosa dopo il tempio
fair playing senza indizi senza che te
lo aspetti fantastico rinuncia come stai
una dai e non possono dare una parte
allora capì hunter kill
ok possa andare
madonna si sta chiudendo tutto
tutto si sta chiedendo cioè dove dove
non devo andare si chiude fantastico
tutto c'è una porta madonna di dio che
ansia il giorno sto sudando cioè non so
non so se non l'ho fatto per sbaglio per
per scherzo non ha solamente sudando
studiando malissimo
ok
oddio sono tornato no vabbè è chiusa
server no autodistruzione
sto male tutto l se stavo fermo qua
potevo stare fermo qua dall'inizio e
avvengono mi fa giusta purga grazie bel
finale
sono orgoglioso di giocare a giochi che
finiscono così perché no perché no
perché no amici perché non ti vedo il
motivo del perché no vero che vi sia
piaciuto questo era veramente finale di
forgotten tunnels episodio tre ragazzi è
un bel mi piace anche marisa termine
della sessione è certo che si chiede m
come sempre ci diamo alle pressioni dei
ragazzi
[Musica]